mehr Platz für Autos diesem Ziel wird in
Ägyptens Hauptstadt Kairo alles
untergeordnet und deshalb werden überall
in der Stadt alte Bäume gefällt für
Häuser und Wohnungen vor allem aber für
Straßen und Brücken
gesessen und im Park Fußball gespielt
und wir konnten noch überall zu Fuß
hingehen
Heliopolis aufgewachsen großzügig
weitläufig mit gepflegten Parks so wurde
der Stadtteil Anfang des 20 Jahrhunderts
angelegt und so blieb er auch lange Zeit
war voller Gärten und Bäume in den
letzten zwei bis drei Jahren verschwand
das Grün aber nach und nach zwischen den
Fahrspuren standen Bäume die waren
manchmal 80 oder 100 Jahre alt sie
werden einfach gefällt um die Straßen zu
erweitern
und jede neue Straße zieht mehr Verkehr
an ein funktionierendes U-Bahn-Netz gibt
es in Kairo erst den Ansätzen die Busse
sind überfüllt
in einer Stadt in der in großen Teilen
des Jahres Temperaturen zwischen 30 und
40 Grad herrschen wird das Auto so das
Mittel der Fortbewegung
keine Bäume sind gibt es auch keine
Schatten mehr also geht jeder zu Fuß
jeder nimmt das Auto und so gibt es
immer mehr Verkehr
im November soll in Sharm el Sheikh der
große
un-umweltgipfelkopf 27 stattfinden
Ägypten tut alles um sich der Welt als
Grüne und umweltbewusste Nationen zu
präsentieren schuhgrill Asma und seine
Freunde haben sich im Vorfeld dieser
Konferenz zu einer Umweltinitiative
zusammengeschlossen bürgerliches
Engagement in Ägypten immer noch ein
ungewöhnlicher Schritt aber sie hoffen
dass die Konferenz auch im Land selbst
etwas verändert
es soll nicht nur darum gehen eine
Konferenz auszurichten sondern wirklich
etwas für die Umwelt zu tun und für das
Umwelt Bewusstsein
ich versuche zu tun was möglich ist wir
brauchen zum Beispiel Fahrradspuren
einen öffentlichen Nahverkehr oder auch
einfach nur eine Ampel damit wir über
die Straße kommen
überall verschwindet das Grün das war
für mich der Grund mitzumachen es geht
schließlich um das Klima
die ägyptische Regierung hat versprochen
in den nächsten Jahren 100 Millionen
Bäume zu pflanzen wo und wann genau
diese Maßnahmen stattfinden sollen weiß
niemand aber immer mehr setzt sich die
Erkenntnis durch umweltschutz ist zu
wichtig um ihn allein der Regierung zu
überlassen auch in der Oma
ebenacher-tab-schule haben Sie sich
entschieden nicht länger auf Maßnahmen
der Regierung zu warten sondern selbst
etwas für die Umwelt zu tun
unvorstellbar hohe Temperaturen hier
außerdem sehr hohe CO2 Werte also werden
wir Bäume pflanzen außerdem produzieren
Bäume den Sauerstoff den wir brauchen
auch viele seiner Schülerinnen und
Schüler machen mit denn sie alle haben
schon gesehen wie Stück für Stück eine
ehemals grüne Umgebung verschwindet
aber Hessen bin ich sehe wie sie diese
Bäume Abholzen ist das als ob sie eine
Seele töten hier gibt es nichts Schönes
mehr zu sehen
27.000 Bäume will die Initiative bis zur
großen Klimakonferenz Kopf 27 im
November Pflanzen
27.000 vielleicht nicht viel aber jeder
Baum ein Zeichen der Hoffnung Spender
finanzieren das Vorhaben
wir wollen Bäume nicht nur im
öffentlichen Raum und in Schulen wir
wollen auch die alte Kultur von Pflanzen
auf Balkonen und Dächern wiederbeleben
aber die Initiative denkt noch weiter
sie hat nicht nur den Traum von grünen
und blühenden Bäumen sie pflanzt
Obstbäume jeder der vorbeikommt soll
sich später einmal an den Früchten
bedienen dürfen ein gartenebenen Kairo
und eine große grüne blühende Stadt ganz
so wie früher